[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans votre
émission 7 8 le débat jeudi dernier 35%
des cheminots ont exercé leur droit de
grève
ils étaient entre 13 et 25 mai à paris
pour protester contre l'ouverture à la
concurrence du rail face aux
propositions de la réforme de la sncf
les syndicats bordeaux des muscles ils
ont décidé d'organiser une grève quasi
permanente ces trois prochains mois
quelles seront les conséquences de cette
longue grève et que devrait changer la
libéralisation des chemins de fer dans
les yvelines pour débattre j'accueille
autour de moi père pierre jauniaux je
vais y arriver secret gôniots
excusez-moi secrétaire général adjoint
de la cgt cheminots attrape les
également gaël barbotin ce conseiller
régional l'est républicain pompiers
merci d'avoir accepté cette invitation
alors l'ouverture à la concurrence c'est
une ancienne affaire ça l'a été a
proposé que par la commission européenne
votée par le parlement européen est
adoptée par les 28 gouvernement de
l'union cela fait des années que les
centrales ferroviaire notamment la cgt
manifestent contre son application
cependant aujourd'hui force est de
constater que
sncf va bientôt ne plus avoir de
monopole sur le rail aux français
aujourd'hui concrètement qu'est ce que
vous attendez
alors en fait pour préciser comme un
petit peu c'est que les gouvernements
sont six en capacité de sortir des
directives d'ouverture à la concurrence
un certain nombre de domaines notamment
dans les services publics
je rassure tout le monde aucun des
gouvernements depuis une trentaine
d'années de gauche ou de droite
d'ailleurs ne s'est empressé de sortir
par exemple ferroviaire de ce système là
un cordon pour l'état français doit
faire une sorte d'exception pour le so
lu ment il ya des pays qui l'ont fait en
europe 1 je pense au portugal par
exemple
donc voilà et puis donc en ce qui nous
concerne nous nous battons contre la
réforme engagée par le gouvernement de
monsieur philippe et par les ordonnances
évidemment ce qui pour nous est
confiscatoire du débat concernant le
ferroviaire
on pense que les usagers les jeunes ont
tout à fait leur mot à dire dans dans ce
conte ce qu'on doit en faire on n'est
pas contre une réforme nous est contre
ce moyen je rencontre ce type de réforme
la bagarre n'est absolument pas contre
une réforme
puisqu'il ya déjà des réformes qui ont
été engagées par avant et qui sont tout
à fait néfaste au fonctionnement de
l'entreprise
d'accord on va revenir ensuite plus en
détail à la dessus quant à vous vous
partager la position de la présidente de
la région ile de france valérie pécresse
ce qui s'est dit favorable notamment
justement cette ouverture à la
concurrence sur les lignes de chemin de
fer pourquoi tout est fait je pense que
l'ouverture à la concurrence sur
l'ensemble des lignes de chemin de fer
est la suite logique de la mise en
oeuvre au niveau européen d'une démarche
de d'amélioration de l'ensemble de la de
l'offre en matière
en matière de transport 7 quand on fait
le constat aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit
d'ailleurs la preuve en est en ce qui
concerne les mouvements qui sont en
train de se mettre en place
qu'il y a un problème existentiel dans
le fonctionnement au quotidien de
l'ensemble des moyens de transport et
notamment des moyens de transport liées
au train cette libéralisation va
améliorer la situation actuelle est bien
vrai qu'avoir une fluidité le meilleure
fluidité le meilleur réponse je dirais
de l'offre de la mise en adéquation par
rapport en même temps aux besoins des
usagers au quotidien de faire en sorte
que les usagers client puisse à moment
donné à voir un retour qui soit effectif
quand on constate aujourd'hui ne serait
ce que sur l'île de france j'ai encore
ce matin petit sms et peut-être
anecdotique mais de manière régulière
les retards qui sont enclenchées qui
existe aujourd'hui sur l'ensemble des
voies de chemin de fer mais notamment
les deux c'est un moyen c'est une
solution qui peut éventuellement
apporter apporter des réponses aux
problématiques rencontrées aujourd'hui
notamment par les usagers à l'actualité
donc cette grève prolongée qui se
profile qui va débuter notamment le 3
avril duré pendant trois mois et sera on
peut alterner entre grèves et accalmies
deux jours de grève trois jours sans
deux jours de grève jusqu'au 28 juin
est ce que vous n'avez pas peur de
retourner l'opinion publique contre vous
en faisant ça en fait
même s'il ya un gros effort qui est fait
pour faire croire aux gens que la
majorité des gens ne nous comprennent
pas ou se retourne contre nous je tiens
quand même à préciser que les usagers
pour le coup on les a tous les jours
devant nous et là je parle en tant que
cheminot mais en tant que responsable
syndical on y va tous les jours aussi
dans les gares pour leur expliquer le
pourquoi du comment des des problèmes
quasi quotidiens en fait des
suppressions de trains des retards de
trains qui sont plus du
sous-investissement qui est du fait du
politique pour le coup c'est pas c'est
pas légion et nous pensons responsable
et également à une déstructuration pour
pas dire un sabotage production des
trains qui organisé de longue date par
la direction de la sncf avec l'aval du
gouvernement puisque on est une
entreprise publique et la direction sncf
doit rendre des comptes au gouvernement
notamment avec
ce qu'on appelle la gestion par activité
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui un
conducteur est borné dans une activité
par exemple le transilien et où le thé
vert et 6 à 1 transilien où il manque un
conducteur et ben si un conducteur
circulant réserve à côté non seulement
on va payer le entre guillemets le
conducteur de réserve a continué une
réserve et on va supprimer le transilien
parce que la direction a décidé ainsi ça
ne fonctionnait pas comme ça il ya dix
ans par les maires encore une fois les
avoir d'après vos de la prévention
expliqué des choses que je savais c'est
une chose mais ensuite ce par exemple la
semaine dernière il y appelle du tout eu
de ligne aile par exemple dans le
département c'est quand même autre chose
aussi
c'est aussi montrer que quand les gens
vont pas au travail tout de suite ça
marche moins bien je dire parce que
c'est pour ça que je disais que
normalement les usagers des cheminots
devrait être au coeur des débats au
coeur de l'établissement d'une vraie
réforme du ferroviaire en est totalement
exclue par ailleurs le gouvernement
s'est empressé alors pour le coup de
nous mettre en campagne de dénigrement
absolument incroyable sur le dos on nous
faisant passer pour pour je ne sais quel
nantis ou privilégiée mais cette sauce
là ne prend pas je vous dis non et
auprès des usagers
et très sincèrement j'étais mercredi
soir donc avant la grève au travail et
j'ai traîné un peu à montparnasse
les gens venaient tout à fait gentiment
demandé les horaires du lendemain pour
la grève
et personne n'est venu nous invectiver
voilà donc je pense que nous notre rôle
en tant que syndicat par exemple c'est
justement d'aller expliquer aux gens
pourquoi on fait grève et je pense très
sincèrement que la majorité d'entre nous
comprennent pas ce qu ils le subissent
au quotidien pour revenir notamment
justement soit cette libéralisation sur
le calendrier pour mettre les choses au
clair notamment c'est à partir de 2021
que les tgv vont être ouverts à la
concurrence et à partir de 2019 les
premières régions vont pouvoir ouvrir
certains ter à la concurrence
cependant la région ile de france est
une exception puisqu'il n'y aura pas de
nos concurrents la sncf le second tome i
de 40 est ce que vous vous regretter
cette décision
moi je pense que la région ile-de-france
fait chéri fait exception au travers
justement du fait qu'elle soit la
première région on voit dire le bassin
économique à la fois au niveau national
et au niveau au niveau européen elle
fait partie des tous premiers je dirais
bassin d'emploi à partir de là il ya
besoin justement d'une analyse qui soit
fine en matière d'évolution des
transports faire une évolution de
transport qui soit je dirais à marche
forcée oui pourquoi pas mais à condition
qu'on ait bien compris que ce qui est au
coeur du dispositif à mettre en oeuvre
certes les cheminots mais avant les
cheminots ce sont là encore les clients
les usagers ce gène est quelque part
ceux qui vont être amenés à payer et
donc à partir de là inverser le
processus en dix ans celui qui est au
coeur du dispositif qui est celui pour
lequel la réforme peut être mené par don
c'est avant tout les cheminots non moi
je pense que c'est avant tout pour les
usagers dont il ya une analyse préalable
qui est à faire des études qui sont à
mettre en oeuvre de bien valider les
choses et faire en sorte que certes en
quand la bascule pourra se mettre en
oeuvre et bien que l'ensemble l'ensemble
soit cohérent qui aimeraient y tiennent
la route pas dire ressemblera justement
saura dans cette volonté d'ouvrir à la
concurrence le chemin de fer c'est un
monopole naturel je sais pas si vous
connaissez le concept c'est à dire que
de toute façon il n'y a qu'une
infrastructure parce qu'on peut
promettre cinquante mille voix les unes
à côté des autres
chacune pour une compagnie différente
donc on passera d'un monopole public à
un monopole privé et dans ce contexte là
la formation d'un cheminot et sert à
l'achat de matériel ça coûte très cher
c'est long c'est sont des formations
techniques qui ne se font pas comme ça
donc ce qui va se passer c'est qu'on va
changer d'opérateur on aura les mêmes
cheminots les mêmes le même matériel et
les mêmes infrastructures le sous
financement dans les infrastructures que
ce soit veolia keolis ou sncf ça change
rien on aura les mêmes causes avec les
mêmes effets donc c'est tout à fait
irréaliste d'imaginer que l'ouverture à
la concurrence va changer quelque chose
hormis une chose qui va changer ça va
être le prix pour l'usager et je vous
prie de regarder tous les pays autour de
nous qui l'ont fait non seulement
le prix du transport est infiniment plus
cher qu'en france tant pour les usagers
que pour le contribuable
parce que je vous rappelle quand même
que je suis ne sont aussi contribuables
donc on est aussi contributeurs de notre
chemin de fer au delà le au delà de le
produire et j il suffit de voir les les
exemples très concrets qui sont à côté
de nous à tel point que les britanniques
veulent un retour à la nationalisation
de l'ensemble des chemins de fer sur
leur pays donc je sais cependant pour
les britanniques c'est vraiment un
exemple vraiment con cas où
effectivement le service s'est vraiment
effondré mais si on regarde notamment
l'allemagne qui avait la concurrence en
94 il a toujours une sorte de monopole
de la deutsche bahn mais par contre si
tu as dit les prix des billets est
remonté en bc oui mais c'est pas bien
sûr mais surtout si on prend juste
l'allemagne intoxiquent cistes des
exemples sélection si on reprend juste
l'allemagne je suis désolé il est
beaucoup d'allemands prennent beaucoup
le cas parce que le travail trop cher
accor justement donc on a besoin ce
qu'il fasse est une question c'est une
configuration gérer de d'ensemble qu'est
ce que ça a changé parce que là on a dit
que les prix vont augmenter que le
service ne sera pas là est-ce que vous
êtes diagnostic non je pense que
diagnostic il est le diagnostic n'est
pas fondée je dirais quelques pas
justement quand on parle de cette
attente 2040 pour pouvoir mettre en
place une dimension opérationnelle de la
concurrence sur les voies de chemin de
fer c'est c'est justement d'avoir une
bonne adéquation entre à la fois un
service rendu
le la prise de participation
l'accompagnement aussi malgré tout gérer
du secteur des politiques au travers par
exemple de la région ile de france quand
on voit un niveau de la région ile de
france
les sommes qui sont investis aujourd'hui
pour la mise à niveau mais non seulement
de la partie chemin de fer mais de
l'ensemble qui a cette complémentarité
qui a joué et menacer à ces cas là ce
qui n'a pas un risque justement que les
lignes moins rentables soient moins
desservis voir un certain temps sans
abandonner alors à partir du moment
alors sur l'île de france si on parle de
l'île de france et il est moins rentable
je pense que là on a
il y a est ce que par exemple coignières
ou villepreux seront moins desservis que
les grands gars comme saint-quentin ou
alors vers salle
est-ce qu'il ya ce risque-là de
justement à mon sens en décalage que je
n'ai pas les os clairement aujourd'hui
les études ne démontre pas que il va
falloir les arrêter ou les poursuivre je
dirais qu'on est dans une phase
aujourd'hui de croissance de l'île de
france pour lesquels il est important
d'apporter des moyens de gérer des
réponses en transport mais en moyens de
transport qu'ils soient en adéquation
avec la réalité de la zone dans laquelle
on se trouve il ya à la fois sur l'île
de france une zone extrêmement densément
peuplées qui est
paris la petite couronne on va dire le
bassin est bien entre aujourd'hui et
demain si les rajustements une
différenciation beaucoup plus eh bien il
va y avoir il faut y avoir je tirais des
grands pôles multimodaux qui doivent
pouvoir se mettre en place à partir
desquels justement d'autres moyens de
transport devront pouvoir aussi rayonner
dans des quatre mains de chemin de fer
notamment à villepreux et plus de la
question se pose cependant la question
ne se pose pas en plus ou en moins à la
question c'est en termes de l'équation
par rapport à la réalité du terrain
qu'est ce qui aujourd'hui est une
réponse en adéquation avec les besoins
des populations qui sont qui sont
desservis si jamais on ne pense que
chemin de fer
aujourd'hui vous avez d impossibilité de
pouvoir développer par exemple des voies
de chemin de fer mais qui sont notamment
les tangentielles on a besoin on aurait
peut-être besoin justement les
redévelopper fait pas forcément travers
la sncf que je pense à une 18 favé il ya
tout un tas de schéma de transport qui
doivent jouer la complémentarité les uns
par rapport aux autres et faire en sorte
que donc peut-être un peu moins de
chemin de fer et plein d'autres choix
âgées pas de réponse aujourd'hui je n'ai
pas la réponse graduée en tout cas ce
qui est important justement ça va être
de trouver cette adéquation par rapport
à l'évolution de l'ensemble de la région
ile de france qui est en pleine mutation
aujourd'hui en matière de croissance
démographique et en matière de
réimplantation de deux bassins de bassin
d'emploi bassin de bassin de vie tous
incarnent vous
grande restructuration c'est pas du tout
de quoi sera fait demain notamment pour
les zones des gars un peu moins
desservis risque d'avoir une
augmentation du prix ados mais ça c'est
une évidence je dire si on prend sur un
écran en france on a un très bel exemple
qu'on a quand même l'ouverture d'un
autre monopole naturel qui est l'énergie
depuis l'ouverture à la concurrence
l'électricité augmentent et qui rendent
pour tsonga s'est quasiment 70
je veux dire donc un moment il faut être
regardé un peu l'histoire on peut pas se
faire table rase du passé comme si moi
je veux dire la fin la cgt elle apporte
des contre-propositions il faut refaire
du chemin de fer en complémentarité avec
d'autres évidemment enfin je veux dire
on sait bien sûr que le train il n'y
aura pas desservir chaque maison ça on
sait bien évidemment mais à l'heure où
on essaye de parler d'écologie ou où on
sait par exemple que les coûts des
bouchons sur la région parisienne c'est
énorme je veux dire vous savez bien je
crois que ya pas très longtemps vous
avez a voté un plan à 20 millions
d'euros contre contrebas sur ce problème
là le le chemin de fer est quand même un
transport de masse puisqu'on travaille à
train c'est entre 1000 et 1500 personnes
oui il faut à un moment choisi de faux
il faut se mettre autour d'une table
il faut y réfléchir mais faut se mettre
autour d'une table quand je dis que les
cheminots ils ont leur mot à dire
je vous avez vous ne dépensez 500 ans je
sais plus combien de millions pour
acheter
42 rames dirige zen on appelle ça tout à
fait voilà donc madame pécresse est très
exaltante a fait des photos avec les
journalistes à la sncf tout le monde
sait que ça ne marche pas ces gens là on
en a sur la ligne paris chartres le mans
ça tourne tout le temps au palais ça
peut pas rouler en hiver et sa pop art
ou en automne titre heymans simplement
je dirais qu'aujourd'hui les rames qui
sont qui sont implantés sur les scènes
marche pas ça ne marche pas pourquoi
seuls face à ne marche pas je suis pas
la démonstration aujourd'hui que ces
rames ne marche pas puisque toute façon
sur la ligne n
notamment les nouveaux trains sont pas
encore mis en place sur sur cette ligne
très serré nous on a besoin aujourd'hui
qu'ils soient de deux trains qui soit
une ponction commandé 1
à terme il ya 81 80 nouvelles rames qui
vont être implantés soit une haine qui
comme celle qui nous concerne le plus
puisque celle qui fasse entre
rambouillet paris montparnasse et
l'ensemble de ces rames ont vocation
aussi aujourd'hui être une réponse une
réponse aux besoins des personnes
transportées notamment avoir la
possibilité de connexion wifi la
possibilité d'être dans un environnement
sécurisé en tout cas notamment avec la
vidéo protection à l'intérieur des
trains
donc là on a aujourd'hui une nécessité
de migration de mutation gérer
l'ensemble du matériel ferroviaire et la
qualité du matériel ferroviaire gerry
qui existent aujourd'hui c'est aussi
celui là qui ne marche pas ou qui ne
marchent plus peut-être par usure
puisque les petits gris ou encore 42 50
ans qu'à un moment donné il ya
l'évolution du matériel
il faut la prendre en compte il ya
certainement encore des améliorations
puissent apprendre
m oui ça s'arrache ses mots car si ça
sera menacé jusqu'à le regio 2n on en a
déjà sur la ligne paris chartres le mans
c'est un le connaît c'est dangereux
l'hiver dernier il ya des sections de
lignes entières où il était interdit de
rouler parce qu'avec un seul pantographe
voyez vous on a 80 ans d'histoire de
chemin de fer derrière nous avec le la
traction électrique
on a toujours su périmètre de
pantographe plein d'amis qu'un seul je
vous dis d'emblée ça va être une
catastrophe
vous verrez bien mais je vous le dit et
c'est dommage que l'on n'ait pas été
consulté sur le sujet la fin ça devient
un peu trop technique mais merci à vous
en tout cas d'avoir accepté de
participer à cette émission je vous êtes
à voir et revoir cette émission sur
notre site internet
bonne soirée à tous et la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]